Pero cómo entiende la oposición esta
detención
Gracias Rodrigo Un saludo para usted y
para todo el mundo en la oposición y el
departamento de Santa Cruz Soy
parlamentario del departamento de Santa
Cruz
entiende esta detención como un
secuestro un secuestro totalmente ilegal
y una afrenta de manera directa a la
democracia a la oposición Y por supuesto
al departamento de Santa Cruz que tiene
un bastión De oposición muy fuerte y Que
obviamente tiene un gobernador electo
con más de ochocientos cincuenta y dos
mil votos con un cincuenta y cinco por
ciento de aprobación y elección por
supuesto para ser gobernador es un
secuestro así lo entendemos y así lo
vemos desde Santa Cruz y cuáles son las
acciones legales que pretenden seguir de
ahora en adelante
bueno no confiamos en la justicia
consideramos que no existe un estado de
derecho en el país y más bien la gente
está enardecida Y por supuesto algo
confundida porque hasta donde podemos
entender no existía una orden de
aprehensión nunca se la mostró este
secuestro que ha sufrido el gobernador
con una dirección desconocida de primera
instancia más de dos horas sin saber de
él entendemos ya que está detenido en la
ciudad de la paz y obviamente como no
existe justicia las acciones van a ser
De hecho estoy en el comité cívico en
este momento ha habido una reunión de
emergencia y el comité cívico está
determinando
una asamblea de la cruceñidad para el
día de mañana entre diez y once de la
mañana para determinar acciones
concretas para la liberación del
gobernador Luis Fernando Camacho y está
capturado Abre de nuevo una brecha
entonces con el gobierno que se creía
superada tras las protestas sociales de
noviembre hay posibilidades aún de
diálogo con el gobierno
pareciera que este más bien el inicio de
una dictadura proclamada en democracia y
entendemos también de que es una
persecución a la oposición es por
supuesto una violación a todos los
derechos constitucionales que tiene el
gobernador y que tenemos los opositores
de defendernos de acusaciones falsas se
habla de un golpe uno golpe dos no
existió golpe en este país hubo una
sucesión constitucional en la que por
supuesto el presidente o expresidente
Evo Morales renunció a partir de una
presión social porque se lo acusó
precisamente de fraude ese fraude nunca
fue investigado el padrón electoral
sigue contaminado Y por supuesto el
gobierno ejerce presión sobre la
oposición persiguiendo la sobre
acusación es totalmente falsa y es lo
que está sucediendo con el caso uno caso
dos y cualquier caso de golpe tenemos
presa una expresidente que la señora
Yanine añe y hay un pronunciamiento
internacional insistente en
en ese sentido